[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 26 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actualité locale et
régionale tout de suite les titres de ce
mercredi 21 mars 21 mars date chaque
année de la journée mondiale de la
trisomie 21 l'occasion de sensibiliser
sur la maladie un grand colloque se
déroule de demain jeudi à samedi à l'ufr
des sciences de la santé de l'ue vs qu
un événement à l'initiative de
l'association française pour la
recherche sur la trisomie 21
son président jacques coste il est notre
invité 25 hectares de déchets accumulés
depuis dix ans une grande décharge
sauvage s'étend sur trois communes du
nord des yvelines un habitant de
carrières sous poissy vient de lancer un
cri d'alarmé pour que la situation
s'améliore est la remise en état du
terrain pourrait coûter très cher
reportage à carrières sous poissy
enfin c'est au profit d'emmaüs france le
dressing du coeur se tient jusqu'à la
fin mars
les boutiques de mode indépendante
collecte des habits dont vous ne voulez
plus trois magasins de versailles y
participent
nous recevons jean-loup becker vice
président de la fédération nationale de
l'habillement qui organise l'opération
grosse journée de mobilisation demain
jeudi 22 mars les cheminots et
l'ensemble de la fonction publique se
mobilisent avec un jeudi noir en
prévision les perturbations et débute
dès ce soir 19 heures notamment dans les
transports
aucun train ne circulera sur la ligne e
du transilien pour la ligne n prévoir 1
train sur 2 le trafic sera interrompu
sur l'ex plaisir de re et sur le réseau
du rer c c'est un train sur trois armez
vous de patience et consulter
régulièrement les horaires sur le site
transilien.com à noter également que des
écoles et des nombreux services de
nombreux services ne seront pas assurés
dont les communes et pour vous informer
sur votre ville votre commune vous
invite à vous rendre sur les différents
sites internet des communes avant de
parler de cette journée mondiale de la
trisomie 21
cette chanson d'abord interprété par des
jeunes de guyancourt pour sensibiliser
au handicap est lundi les membres du
conseil municipal des enfants sont
montés sur la scène de l'école
municipale de musique
le public a pu découvrir leurs créations
reportage de camille lambert et nicolas
d'andré
[Musique]
avec nous
ensemble tout est possible nouvelle
chanson du paysage guyancourt toi un
titre entièrement écrit et interprété
par le conseil municipal des enfants
pour sensibiliser au handicap
on parle d'être tous ensemble tous et
tous réunis donc ça veut dire que en
s'entraidant ça peut faire ça peut aider
les handicapés à faire comme si il
n'était pas vraiment très handicapée qui
qu'il est comme des personnes normes à
une personne normale qu'on est n'importe
quoi quand et n'importe quoi qu'on soit
handicapé de quelque chose une autre
chose est pas on est tous ces cons un
véritable travail de composition menée
depuis la rentrée
les six membres du conseil municipal des
enfants ont rédigé les paroles mises en
musique par des professionnels c'est
avec l'école de musique de la ville
qu'ils l'ont chanté devant le public
mon rôle a été principalement de faire
travailler sur le plan vocal les enfants
et de pouvoir aussi
faire travailler la chanson avec mes
élèves de manière à former un groupe
solidaire une solidarité qui a rassemblé
différents acteurs de la ville pour un
même message
[Musique]
adri fils
je vous le disais dans les titres c'est
aujourd'hui la journée mondiale de la
trisomie 21 comme tous les 21 mars elle
sert à sensibiliser sur la pathologie
mais aussi à faire le point sur
l'avancée de la recherche
bonsoir jacques costil bons joueurs vous
êtes le président de l'aef et retisser
l'association française pour la
recherche sur la trisomie 21 alors à
l'occasion de cette journée mondiale
votre association organise un grand
colloque trisomie 21
évolution et perspectives trois jours de
programme à l'ufr des sciences de la
santé de l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines c'est à montigny le
bretonneux
on va en parler dans un instant déjà un
point de définition sur la la trisomie
21 les personnes malades ont en fait
trois chromosomes 21 au lieu de deux
qu'est ce que ça change concrètement ça
change beaucoup et notamment le faciès
la façon d'être
quelques-uns des problèmes cardiaques
dès l'année change maintenant avec les
progrès de la médecine
on a pu sauver beaucoup de personnes
seront là d'accord le problème cognitif
qui sont très connues par tous y en a
qui sont plus fragiles que d'autres à
pouvoir parler et avoir un langage
approprié l'antique que personne ne le
valide mais c'est celle à cogiter de la
trisomie 21 c'est que via une grande
variante de la variable entre
différentes personnes les différents les
différents malades alors sur cette
journée mondiale c'est la 13e
aujourd'hui elle a été initiée
d'ailleurs par votre association les 21
mars 2005 tout à 21,03 finalement qui
fait référence aux trois chromosomes
c'est pour ça que vous avez choisi cette
date du 13 mai étions trois à nous et
nous étions trois heures d'accord d'un
petit petite salle de réunion
université jusu à l'époque et donc voilà
c'est comme ça écrivait qui est née
cette journée qui n'a rien à voir avec
la loi du 11 février 2005
parce que déjà organisé un colloque ça
demande du temps
donc le chêne n'était pas ça chez
trouvait à être comme ça mais ça n'a
rien à voir
alors on précise d'ailleurs que la
journée a été reconnue depuis par l' oms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé par
l'onu également en te poser les
objectifs tout à l'heure c'est
sensibiliser sur la maladie faire un
point si sûr sur l'avancée de la
recherche tout op maintenant de
différents pays du monde 2 organise ce
jour là et que des manifestations
d'accord c'est très bien c'est nous en
france nous organisons puis subitement
un colloque depuis la 13e journée comme
mitigés avec différents thèmes abordés
que ce soit le médical qu'est ce qu'un
flux de matières 1 et on peut passer à
la alors à la scolarité et d'emploi et
ils différents thèmes qui seront abordés
la caisse et quelques cheat codes
notamment cessé au programme la première
journée s'est cassé des codes sur
l'agriculteur est alors comment cette
année nous l'organisons à l'ufr saint
quentin on va nous savons que des
étudiants en médecine
très peu d'heures durant leur cursus des
étudiants en médecine pour sur le
handicap en général ils auront un après
deux heures et où ils vont pouvoir
parler avec un médecin et une personne
qui appelle de la recherche sur lafuma
terre pendant ces deux hommes alors
disait vous avez créé ces journées cette
journée mondiale en 2005 ans en 2018 est
ce que les choses ont évolué ce qu'on
parle plus aujourd'hui de la trisomie 21
on n'a pas beaucoup d'avenir même à la
télévision là je crois que tu n'aies
wish aussi news cet après midi à une
émission sur antenne 2 aujourd'hui le il
ya eu une rencontre paris est seizième
donc voilà c'est quelque chose qui
commença à évoluer comme gta hui dans
son dos aux petits jeunes occupants sur
les champ du handicap en cours donc
voilà même le handicap en général c'est
quelque chose qui commence
on commence à mieux le percevoir et
mieux
se l'approprier l'approché alors sur la
recherche on va pas rentrer dans les
détails vous avez donc n'être pas de
chercheurs mais est-ce qu'on progresse
sur la maladie ce qu'il ya des espoirs
de vaincre cette maladie des peut-être
aidé aussi les personnes à mieux vivre
avec la trisomie 21 20 crown en mieux
vivre du rampeau tête
nous avons d'ailleurs lors de ce
collaborateur qui s'appelle la broque
grandfontaine qui vient avec un composé
les jo d'hiver qui s'appelle du front
top qui améliorent la le cognitif et
comportements des personnes avec une
fiche de matière le problème comme si un
complément alimentaire et que ce soit
déjà des personnes qui ont un peu de
surpoids
c'est toujours un peu délicat de
rajouter ce doublement alimentaire ou à
la preuve est arrivé à gérer mais déçu
autre effet toujours un peu difficile
donc à l aider le chili qui évolue pour
mon plus j'avais encore rien donné
j'attends encore trois ans et je verrai
dans trois ans ce grand colloque qui se
déroule chaque année dans une ville
différente c'est toujours à main
jouant devant nous le oui pour la france
nous avons déjà organisé à paris à lyon
à limoges à grenoble marseille
j'ai tenu à chaque entendu on disait
vous parliez de votre votre fils donc ça
veut dire que vous cette histoire avec
la trisomie 21
l ailier personnellement un fils qui
souffre de cette maladie qui à 32 ans il
n'en souffrent pas et huile avec hugues
à 32 ans en 2001 j'ai rencontré
personnellement me l'a dit qu'il
s'appelle le cancer est un cancer du
poumon
mais je me suis dit de recherche m'a
sauvé qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
leur la recherche pour mon fils
et c'est là que j'ai découvert qu'il
existait une association l'association
française pour la recherche et la
bascule se maintient j'ai appelé sa
présidente qui a fondé la triche la
claque ils l'ont laissée comme ça que je
suis rentré en contact avec cette
personne et dès 2002 vrai ou si j'ai été
opérée le 12 septembre 2001 et en
février 2002 je rentrais dans cette
association très bien donc on rappelle
trois jours de programme pour ce
colloque a lu vs q qu'est ce qu'il faut
retenir du programme de nombreux
spécialistes sur la question qui seront
présents à ouïr même monsieur emmanuel
pire puisque la nouvelle loi sur
l'éthique va être est programmé pour
2019 et donc monsieur sera également
présent le vendredi matin lors des
discours à 8 heures la 9h30 devant
françois 9h30 et madame se fusionne le
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre en
charge des personnes handicapées sera
également présent qu'elle sera présente
donc fait valser pour nous d'ailleurs ce
sera la première fois que tu me radier
placement pour venir un 1 de nos
colonnes que donc on ira ville de ça
qu'est ce que vous attendez de ce
colloque sa 13e colloque est bien qu'à
chaque chambre des parents
moi je suis quand même informé en tant
que présidente de l'association par
différents chercheur et olle mais le but
2-2 d'informer les parents les personnes
même atteint de trisomie 21 personnes
certaines en ont une compréhension
possible et alors qu'ils ne peuvent pas
dire on on va tous sera enregistrée sera
mis en ligne sur notre site avec fierté
et ce colloque sur la trisomie 21 à
l'occasion de cette journée mondiale ans
et de demain à samedi à l'ufr des
sciences de la santé de l'ue vs qu à
montigny le bretonneux merci à jacques
aussi président de la frtp plus
d'informations sur ce colloque sur cette
association et également sur la trisomie
21 au site internet qui s'affiche en bas
de l'écran est dans l'actualité du jour
également la plaine de neauphle attrape
meilleurs lycées des yvelines pour la
quatrième année consécutive c'est
l'enseignement du palmarès des lycées
2018 révélé ce mercredi matin par nos
confrères du parisien
ce classement tient compte du taux de
réussite au baccalauréat mais aussi du
profil social des élèves et de leurs 4
et de la capacité des établissements à
garder leurs élèves de la seconde à la
terminale
dans le top trois on retrouve également
d'autres lycées publics maurepas qui
arrive troisième
plus loin dans le classement d'autres
lycées comme jean vilar à plaisir 16e ou
encore saint françois d'assise 23e et
emilie de breteuil 24e tous deux à
montigny le bretonneux eux n'ont pas eu
à repasser le bac mais un diplôme qui
n'existe plus et qui évoquera des
souvenirs à certains des seniors de
villepreux se sont confrontés de nouveau
certificat d'études primaires examen a
supprimé en 1989 une session était
organisée vendredi dernier aurélie rond
et patrick jacques de dixmude
avec un peu d'imagination on pourrait
presque croire que nous sommes revenus
au début du 20e siècle à l'époque où
l'on passait encore le certificat
d'études
cet après midi 19 seniors de villepreux
ont planché sur les épreuves de ce
diplôme emblématique supprimé il ya 30
ans c'est pas si simple c'est parce
qu'ils somment de se remettre à se
remettre dans le bain après la dictée
place à la rédaction ou encore aux
calculs avant une pause goûter comme au
début du siècle dernier un retour en
arrière fortement apprécié par les
participants
un somme rappelle que je pensais à mon
certificat d'études en 1950
je ne repasse à nouveau et nous ça me
rappelle les bons vieilli tes questions
calcul qu'on faisait dans ce temps là et
qui nous ont donné un très bon
orthographe une très belle calcul mental
que non plus tous les enfants une
opération proposée par la mairie de
villepreux qui avait notamment pour
souhait de créer du lien social
c'est leur permettra de passer un
agréable après-midi et de tisser du lien
que nous puissions aussi tisser du lien
avec eux et qu'ils puissent aussi tisser
du lien entre eux parce qu'ils n'ont pas
tous ont toujours l'occasion de se
rencontrer des élèves studieux
puisqu'ils les ont tous obtenu le fameux
diplôme du certificat d'études primaires
elle appelle au secours lancés par un
riverain de carrières sous poissy des
montagnes de déchets s'accumulent depuis
à 10 ans aujourd'hui plus de 5000 tonnes
de détritus recouvre la terre sur 25
hectares l'équivalent de sept terrains
de football et pour interpeller
l'opinion publique et les élus cet
habitant a lancé une pétition en ligne
la remise en état et pour l'instant si
free à 1 million d'euros mais les coûts
pourraient s'élever à beaucoup plus cher
reportage de sébastien cotait pour vyas
grand paris dans cette décharge sauvage
les ordures s'accumulent
il y à du bois des carcasses de voitures
ou encore une armée de pneus plus
inquiétant on trouve aussi de l'amiante
et toutes sortes de solvants alban
bernard via moins de 500 mètres de cette
déchetterie
depuis 2007 il voit la plaine se remplir
de détritus
moi ya 11 ans quand je venais ici avec
mes enfants faire du vélo on pouvait
circuler aujourd'hui
là il ya des zones où on n'y a même plus
de chemin pour sauver cet espace il a
créé un site internet est lancé une
pétition
plus de 2000 personnes l'ont d'ores et
déjà signé il a répertorié au total plus
de soixante et une zone envahie par les
déchets et là on est sûr
la mer des déchets derrière moselle
l'océan des déchets mais c'est la mer
des déchets qui représente quand même
presque presque way deux hectares 3 ha
complet depuis l'année dernière le
volume de détritus à tripler chaque jour
des camions enchaîne les va-et-vient
comme en témoigne cette vidéo amateur
tournée par un riverain
aujourd'hui la sécurité a été renforcée
autour du site
ces plots en béton tente de faire
barrage et des policiers multiplient les
patrouilles
pourtant les déchets continuent de
s'entasser ans s'est vite aperçu que les
plaques minéralogiques étaient fausses
ou étaient des plaques minéralogiques
roumaine donc la possibilité
d'intervenir et d'avoir une action
efficace pour mettre un terme à tout ça
est très réduite notamment par la
verbalisation
moi ce que j'aimerais justement c'est
que la législation évolue et qu'on
puisse saisir le véhicule même pour une
suspicion de dépôts sauvages
la remise en état du site est évalué à
un million d'euros
mais le coup pourrait être revu à la
hausse des projets de nettoiement et de
redynamisation sont à l'étude comme la
culture du miscanthus une plante qui
dépollue les sols là on est en train de
travailler sur cette phase 2 de cette
opération qui consiste à la fois à
dépolluer par la culture de miscanthus
qui permet de capter le plomb mais
également de porter des cultures un peu
novatrice comme la culture culture hors
sol
le combat continue pour les riverains de
la plaine de carrières sous poissy
ils se mobiliseront le 31 mars prochain
on parle solidarité à présent dans ce
journal avec un nouvel ennemi invités il
m'a rejoint plateau jean louis becker
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le vice
président de la fédération nationale de
l'habillement elle organise jusqu'au 31
mars la 7e édition du dressing du coeur
une grande collecte de vêtements en
boutique de mode indépendante au profit
d'emmaüs france sept magasins des
yvelines au total y participent dont
trois à versailles déjà pour commencer
quel est le concept du dressing du coeur
comment ça marche
le principe c'est que les nos clients
rapportent dans les boutiques les
vêtements qu'ils n'ont plus l'occasion
de porter alors il faut qu'il soit en
bonne état encore qu'ils soient propres
et ses vêtements sont
repris ils sont stockés et la fin de
l'opération nous les donnons à l'antenne
locale d'emmaüs
alors c'est l'occasion de faire un grand
coup de ménage de printemps dans ses
placards le printemps qui a commencé
hier même si on en sait on s'en est pas
rendu compte encore mais vous l'avez dit
des vêtements en bon état quel type de
vêtement on peut on peut donner on peut
donner tout type de vêtement peut donner
tous types de vêtements pour hommes pour
femmes ou pour enfants et il suffit
comme je disais qu'il soit encore en
bêta puisqu'ils vont être donnés à
d'autres personnes on parle souvent
d'objets d'occasion pour des voitures
des appareils électroménagers les
vêtements aussi peuvent avoir une
deuxième vie alors beaucoup de vêtements
ont une deuxième vie il y à une partie
des vêtements qui sont revendus dans des
friperies
il ya une autre partie et c'est celle là
qui nous intéresse c'est celle qui est
de redonner à emmaüs pour que les plus
démunis puissent en profiter
470 mille tonnes de textiles qui sont
jetés chaque année ça sera oui c'est ça
donc c'est l'occasion de d'éviter le
gaspillage au pouvoir donner pour faire
profiter des lignes il y avait beaucoup
trop de vêtements qui allaient dans les
poubelles et maintenant c'est un
mouvement général qui est qui allie à la
fois la solidarité l'écologie pour que
le mans justement garde ses vêtements là
pour qui c'est c'est ce qu'on appelle la
deuxième vie du produit
un mot peut-être sur la fédération
nationale de l'habillement qui organise
cette opération elle a fêté ses 80 ans
cette année
créez donc le 11 janvier 1938 qui
représentait le cette fédération alors
cette fédération représente tous les
magasins indépendants c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ne sont pas dans une chaîne qui
les magasins indépendants qui vendent
des vêtements pour hommes pour femmes ou
pour enfants
c'est de l'ordre de 50 mille magasins en
france alors trois boutiques de
versailles participent à l'opération du
dressing du coeur 2018
je vous propose d'écouter deux d'entre
elles et expliquent pourquoi elles se
sont associés à l'événement au micro de
mélanie potesses on participe au
dressing du coeur pour rendre service
aux clientes et puis en même temps pour
nous faire de la publicité
c'est un acte de solidarité et puis bon
on est tous un peu comme ça et les
choses qu'on ne met plus et des choses
qu'on met des choses ça nous empêchera
pas d'acheter que de toute façon des
vêtements des chaussures ou autre donc
c'est une bonne manière de faire
profiter quelqu'un d'autres personnes
jean lebas on l'a entendu opération de
solidarité ça permet aussi de faire
peut-être un peu de pub pour ces
commerçants ces commerces de mode
indépendant face à la concurrence des
grandes enseignes aussi c'est un petit
peu de pub bienvenus je pense que c'est
surtout la façon de montrer que nous
sommes tous solidaires
quant à eux et qui dit à part depuis
justement que les grandes enseignes tout
ça qu'ils font quelque chose
plus de 500 magasins en france magasins
indépendants participent à l'opération
c'est la septième édition est ce que
c'est une opération qui fonctionne bien
le nombre de
boutiques participantes augmente chaque
année le nombre de dons aussi le nombre
de boutiques participantes de par
rapport à la première édition on a plus
que doublé d'accord donc vous voyez c
est la quantité de vêtements on est
autour d'eux
quarante mille
et enfin cape town pour une autre
opération alors du coup la 7e édition se
tient jusqu'à la fin mars dernière
question quelles sont vos attentes pour
cette septième édition justement pour
cette septième édition nos attentes sont
que nos clients viana et rapporte je
dois dire que je suis déjà un petit peu
étonné par la qualité de ce qu'ils
rapportent puisque
j'ai des magasins et dans ses magasins
là on a déjà un grand nombre de sacs qui
sont déjà revenus
merci jean l'aube est fière d'avoir été
avec nous merci vice président de la
fédération nationale de l'habillement
elle organise donc jusqu'au 31 mars la
7e édition du dressing du coeur plus
d'informations sur le site internet et
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
c'est un adage connu l'artisanat est le
premier employeur de france plus d'un
million d'entreprises du secteur sur
l'ensemble du territoire alimentation
fabrication à btp lé domaine sont variés
et permettent de défendre des savoir
faire historique est la chambre de
métiers de l'artisanat récompenser les
artisans des yvelines lundi soir pour
les carrières les plus longues parmi les
décorés allant voter un boulanger arrivé
à magny les hameaux au début des années
90 rencontre signé et nicolas
kirillovitch et patrick jacques de
dixmude
c'est un geste qu'alain mottez répète
presque tous les jours depuis 26 ans
vers la fin de la mêlée cet artisan est
installé à magny les hameaux depuis 1992
baguette croissant et pâtisseries dans
cette boulangerie tout est fait maison
pour l'amour d'un métier débuté à l'âge
de treize ans et qu'il est difficile de
quitter même officiellement retraité je
me fais plus aujourd'hui quelle fille je
m'arrêtais du jour au lendemain comme ça
ça ferait ça pouvait être dangereux
donc maintenant je suis un peu plus au
contact de la clientèle
il est ressorti gérer directement bon
bref c'est pas grave qui viennent se
servir des critiques pour durer mais
surtout toujours resté dans l'ombre
même quand il s'agit d'être récompensée
pour son travail alain mottez doit
forcer un naturel timide et plutôt gêné
[Applaudissements]
ce soir la remise officielle de
médailles à l'hôtel de ville de
versailles par la chambre de métiers et
de l'artisanat comme à lamotte et une
cinquantaine de chefs d'entreprise sont
décorés pour leur savoir faire
ce sont des gens qui pour beaucoup sont
relativement réservés maîtrise des
savoirs ancestraux et sont tellement
impliqué dans leur entreprise qu'ils ont
du mal à en parler
cette cérémonie c'est aussi l'occasion
de les mettre à l'honneur de les mettre
au devant de la scène l'artisanat
premier employeur de france chaque année
plus de cent cinquante mille entreprises
sont créées dans le secteur beaucoup
moins en revanche dur comme la
boulangerie mottez plus de 25 ans à
l'ouverture au public est prévue demain
jeudi un escape game débarque à montigny
le bretonneux place paul claudel concept
importé du japon l'activité se fait par
équipe vous êtes enfermé dans une zac
dans une salle et vous avez 60 minutes
pour en sortir
en résolvant des énigmes ou défi
l'espace de 375 mètres carrés proposera
à partir de demain 3 scénario est
différent présentation au micro de
michael et demi d'euros mission secrète
dans un opéra dans laquelle les joueurs
incarnent un groupe d'agents secrets qui
doit dérober des documents dans le
coffre du directeur national du théâtre
de saint pétersbourg ensuite on a les
reliques maudite qui est un scénario
adapté aux
aux débutants ou non initiés plutôt dans
lequel vous incarnez un groupe
d'explorateurs qui est frappé par une
malédiction et vous décidé de rentrer
dans le tombeau de toutankhamon pour
aller rechercher un artefact qui vous
permettra de mettre fin à cette
malédiction et enfin l'opération
tournesol qui est un braquage de musée
où vous incarnez un groupe d'experts
cambrioleurs qui remplaçait au pied levé
un autre groupe qui s'est
malheureusement fait attraper par la
police
et vous allez
chercher à voler un tableau en
l'occurrence les tournesols de vincent
van gogh pour le compte d'un riche
milliardaire français c'est la fin de ce
journal je vous rappelle cette
information grosse journée de
mobilisation demain les cheminots et
l'ensemble des fonctions des
fonctionnaires publics se mobilisent
avec un jeudi noir en prévision et des
perturbations qui débute dès ce soir 19
heures notamment dans les transports
aucun train ne circulera sur la ligne e
du transilien pour la ligne n prévoir 1
train sur 2 le trafic sera interrompu
sur l'ex plaisir de re enfin sur le
réseau du rer c 7 1 train sur 3 armez
vous de patience et consulter
régulièrement les horaires sur le site
transilien.com à noter également que
plusieurs écoles seront fermées des
services également un non assurés dans
vos communes et pour avoir plus
d'informations rendez vous directement
sur les sites internet de vos communes
ce journal est disponible en replay sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]